you're very supportive of young stand-up
comics and obviously there's two ways
that comedians can go as they get
success they can and you see some that
are it's sort of jealously guard their
success right and you see others that
sort of feel like hey I'm grateful that
I made it and so I'd like to help other
young people you've been great about
that you tweet advice to young stand-ups
you tweet out some advice every single
day yes which is really I mean that's a
lot of advice you have to give you have
to come up with a good piece of advice
for young stand-ups every day well
they're not always good but they are
advice we have one let's take a look at
this these are very good I find pre-show
rituals very helpful in focusing and
relieving anxiety among other things I
say a prayer of gratitude before taking
the stage when I do a TV set as the host
introduced me I turn to the curtain
person and ask can you get me out of
this you did you just did the thing is
our curtain guy hears that all the time
it's from guests it really thought they
were coming on Ellen I am that's a great
thing that you do and and if you getting
a lot of good feedback from the young
con yes they're so grateful and I think
the genesis of it is I have survivor's
guilt because there we see so many
talented people who are nice and funny
and work hard and they haven't had as
much success as I have for luck timing
whatever whatever it is our great hair
yeah exactly this is a wig by the way
they're really a good wig
I could have gotten you out of your
depression so fast oh my word well the
guy who doesn't understand depression
I'll cheer him up
he's completely cured I that's the the
whole thing with depression though is
people would see our hair and think how
could that guy ever be depressed with
hair of a network news anchor yeah I
have the jaw of a superhero and I you
didn't get out of bed you know I know
but then I read Springsteen's
autobiography yes and and that did it
for me yeah because I always thought if
you work hard and you do great things
you'll feel good about yourself and then
it turns out the boss couldn't get out
of bed and at the time he was Bruce
Springsteen yeah yeah and then decided
to remain being Bruce dates yeah yes
yeah he tells me that Prozac is more
effective than being Bruce Springsteen
yeah yeah yeah and if you take enough of
it everyone will feel like they are
Bruce Springsteen signing check